The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Hi, good
afternoon, everyone.
So today, we're
going to be talking
about graph optimizations.
And as a reminder,
on Thursday, we're
going to have a guest lecture
by Professor Johnson of the MIT
Math Department.
And he'll be talking
about performance
of high-level languages.
So please be sure to attend
the guest lecture on Thursday.
So here's an outline
of what I'm going
to be talking about today.
So we're first going to remind
ourselves what a graph is.
And then we're going to
talk about various ways
to represent a graph in memory.
And then we'll talk
about how to implement
an efficient breadth-first
search algorithm, both serially
and also in parallel.
And then I'll talk about how to
use graph compression and graph
reordering to improve the
locality of graph algorithms.
So first of all,
what is a graph?
So a graph contains
vertices and edges,
where vertices represent
certain objects of interest,
and edges between objects model
relationships between the two
objects.
For example, you can
have a social network,
where the people are
represented as vertices
and edges between
people mean that they're
friends with each other.
The edges in this graph don't
have to be bi-directional.
So you could have a
one-way relationship.
For example, if you're looking
at the Twitter network,
Alice could follow Bob,
but Bob doesn't necessarily
have to follow Alice back.
The graph also doesn't
have to be connected.
So here, this graph
here is connected.
But, for example, there
could be some people
who don't like to
talk to other people.
And then they're just off
in their own component.
You can also use graphs to
model protein networks, where
the vertices are proteins,
and edges between vertices
means that there's some
sort of interaction
between the proteins.
So this is useful in
computational biology.
As I said, edges
can be directed,
so their relationship can
go one way or both ways.
In this graph here, we have some
directed edges and then also
some edges that are
directed in both directions.
So here, John follows Alice.
Alice follows Peter.
And then Alice follows Bob,
and Bob also follows Alice.
If you use a graph to
represent the world wide web,
then the vertices
would be websites,
and then the edges would denote
that there is a hyperlink
from one website to another.
And again, the edges here
don't have to be bi-directional
because website A could
have a link to website B.
But website B
doesn't necessarily
have to have a link back.
Edges can also be weighted.
So you can have a
weight on the edge that
denotes the strength
of the relationship
or some sort of distance
measure corresponding
to that relationship.
So here, I have an example
where I am using a graph
to represent cities.
And the edges
between cities have
a weight that corresponds to
the distance between the two
cities.
And if I want to find the
quickest way to get from city A
to city B, then I would
be interested in finding
the shortest path from A
to B in this graph here.
Here's another example,
where the edge weights now
are the costs of a direct
flight from city A to city B.
And here the edges are directed.
So, for example, this
says that there's
a flight from San
Francisco to LA for $45.
And if I want to
find the cheapest
way to get from one
city to another city,
then, again, I would try to find
the shortest path in this graph
from city A to city B.
Vertices and edges can
also have metadata on them,
and they can also have types.
So, for example, here's
the Google Knowledge Graph,
which represents all the
knowledge on the internet
that Google knows about.
And here, the nodes
have metadata on them.
So, for example, the node
corresponding to da Vinci
is labeled with his date
of birth and date of death.
And the vertices
also have a color
corresponding to the type of
knowledge that they refer to.
So you can see that some
of these nodes are blue,
some of them are red,
some of them are green,
and some of them have
other things on them.
So in general, graphs can
have types and metadata
on both the vertices
as well as the edges.
Let's look at some more
applications of graphs.
So graphs are very useful
for implementing queries
on social networks.
So here are some
examples of queries
that you might want to
ask on a social network.
So, for example, you might
be interested in finding
all of your friends who went
to the same high school as you
on Facebook.
So that can be implemented
using a graph algorithm.
You might also be
interested in finding
all of the common friends
you have with somebody else--
again, a graph algorithm.
And a social network service
might run a graph algorithm
to recommend people that
you might know and want
to become friends with.
And they might use
a graph algorithm
to recommend certain
products that you
might be interested in.
So these are all examples
of social network queries.
And there are many
other queries that you
might be interested in
running on a social network.
And many of them
can be implemented
using graph algorithms.
Another important
application is clustering.
So here, the goal is to
find groups of vertices
in a graph that
are well-connected
internally and
poorly-connected externally.
So in this image here, each blob
of vertices of the same color
corresponds to a cluster.
And you can see that
inside a cluster,
there are a lot of edges
going among the vertices.
And between clusters, there
are relatively fewer edges.
And some applications
of clustering
include community detection
and social networks.
So here, you might be
interested in finding
groups of people with
similar interests or hobbies.
You can also use clustering
to detect fraudulent websites
on the internet.
You can use it for
clustering documents.
So you would cluster
documents that
have similar text together.
And clustering is often used
for unsupervised learning
and machine learning
applications.
Another application
is connectomics.
So connectomics is the study
of the structure, the network
structure of the brain.
And here, the vertices
correspond to neurons.
And edges between
two vertices means
that there's some sort of
interaction between the two
neurons.
And recently, there's
been a lot of work
on trying to do
high-performance connectomics.
And some of this work has
been going on here at MIT
by Professor Charles Leiserson
and Professor Nir Shavit's
research group.
So recently, this has
been a very hot area.
Graphs are also used
in computer vision--
for example, in
image segmentation.
So here, you want to
segment your image
into the distinct objects
that appear in the image.
And you can construct a graph
by representing the pixels
as vertices.
And then you would place
an edge between every pair
of neighboring pixels with
a weight that corresponds
to their similarity.
And then you would run some sort
of minimum cost cut algorithm
to partition your graph into
the different objects that
appear in the image.
So there are many
other applications.
And I'm not going to have
time to go through all of them
today.
But here's just a flavor of some
of the applications of graphs.
So any questions so far?
OK, so next, let's
look at how we can
represent a graph in memory.
So for the rest of
this lecture, I'm
going to assume that my vertices
are labeled in the range from 0
to n minus 1.
So they have an
integer in this range.
Sometimes, your graph
might be given to you
where the vertices are
already labeled in this range,
sometimes, not.
But you can always
get these labels
by mapping each
of the identifiers
to a unique integer
in this range.
So for the rest of
the lecture, I'm
just going to assume that
we have these labels from 0
to n minus 1 for the vertices.
One way to represent a graph
is to use an adjacency matrix.
So this is going to
be n by n matrix.
And there's a 1 bit in
i-th row in j-th column
if there's an edge that goes
from vertex I to vertex J,
and 0 otherwise.
Another way to represent a graph
is the edgeless representation,
where we just store a
list of the edges that
appear in the graph.
So we have one
pair for each edge,
where the pair contains the
two coordinates of that edge.
So what is the space
requirement for each
of these two representations in
terms of the number of edges m
and the number of
vertices n in the graph?
So it should be pretty easy.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: n squared
for the [INAUDIBLE]
and m for the [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, so the
space for the adjacency matrix
is order n squared
because you have n
squared cells in this matrix.
And you have 1 bit
for each of the cells.
For the edge list, it's
going to be order m
because you have m edges.
And for each edge, you're
storing a constant amount
of data in the edge list.
So here's another way
to represent a graph.
This is known as the
adjacency list format.
And idea here is
that we're going
to have an array of
pointers, 1 per vertex.
And each pointer points
to a linked list storing
the edges for that vertex.
And the linked list is
unordered in this example.
So what's the space requirement
of this representation?
AUDIENCE: It's n plus m.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so it's
going to be order n plus m.
And this is because
we have n pointers.
And the number of entries
across all of the linked lists
is just equal to the number of
edges in the graph, which is m.
What's one potential issue with
this sort of representation
if you think in terms
of cache performance?
Does anyone see a potential
performance issue here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it
could be [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So the issue here
is that if you're
trying to loop over all of
the neighbors of a vertex,
you're going to have to
dereference the pointer
in every linked list node.
Because these are not
contiguous in memory.
And every time you
dereference linked lists node,
that's going to be a
random access into memory.
So that can be bad
for cache performance.
One way you can improve
cache performance
is instead of using linked
lists for each of these neighbor
lists, you can use an array.
So now you can store the
neighbors just in this array,
and they'll be
contiguous in memory.
One drawback of this
approach is that it
becomes more expensive if you're
trying to update the graph.
And we'll talk more
about that later.
So any questions so far?
So what's another way to
represent the graph that we've
seen in a previous lecture?
What's a more compressed
or compact way
to represent a graph,
especially a sparse graph?
So does anybody remember the
compressed sparse row format?
So we looked at this in
one of the early lectures.
And in that lecture, we used
it to store a sparse matrix.
But you can also use it
to store a sparse graph.
And as a reminder, we have two
arrays in the compressed sparse
row, or CSR format.
We have the Offsets array
and the Edges array.
The Offsets array stores
an offset for each vertex
into the Edges array,
telling us where
the edges for that
particular vertex
begins in the Edges array.
So Offsets of i
stores the offset
of where vertex i's edges
start in the Edges array.
So in this example, vertex
0 has an offset of 0.
So its edges start at
position 0 in the Edges array.
Vertex 1 has an
offset of 4, so it
starts at index 4 in
this Offsets array.
So with this
representation, how can we
get the degree of a vertex?
So we're not storing the
degree explicitly here.
Can we get the
degree efficiently?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so you can
get the degree of a vertex
just by looking
at the difference
between the next offset
and its own offset.
So for vertex 0, you can
see that its degree is 4
because vertex 1's offset is
4, and vertex 0's offset is 0.
And similarly you can do that
for all of the other vertices.
So what's the space usage
of this representation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry,
can you repeat?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so again,
it's going to be order m plus n
because you need order n space
for the Offsets array and order
m space for the Edges array.
You can also store values
or weights on their edges.
One way to do this is to create
an additional array of size m.
And then for edge i, you
just store the weight
or the value in the i-th
index of this additional array
that you created.
If you're always accessing the
weight when you access an edge,
then it's actually better
for a cache locality
to interleave the weights
with the edge targets.
So instead of creating
two arrays of size m,
you have one array of size 2m.
And every other
entry is the weight.
And this improves cache
locality because every time
you access an edge, its weight
is going to be right next to it
in memory.
And it's going to likely
be on the same cache line.
So that's one way to
improve cache locality.
Any questions so far?
So let's look at some
of the trade-offs
in these different
graph representations
that we've looked at so far.
So here, I'm listing
the storage costs
for each of these
representations which
we already discussed.
This is also the cost for just
scanning the whole graph in one
of these representations.
What's the cost of
adding an edge in each
of these representations?
So for adjacency matrix, what's
the cost of adding an edge?
AUDIENCE: Order 1.
JULIAN SHUN: So for
adjacency matrix,
it's just order
1 to add an edge.
Because you have random
access into this matrix,
so you just have to
access to i, j-th entry
and flip the bit from 0 to 1.
What about for the edge list?
So assuming that the
edge list is unordered,
so you don't have to keep
the list in any sorted order.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess it's O of 1.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
again, it's just O of 1
because you can just add it
to the end of the edge list.
So that's a constant time.
What about for the
adjacency list?
So actually, this
depends on whether we're
using linked lists or
arrays for the neighbor
lists of the vertices.
If we're using a linked
list, adding an edge just
takes constant time
because we can just
put it at the beginning
of the linked list.
If we're using an
array, then we actually
need to create a new array
to make space for this edge
that we add.
And that's going to cost
us a degree of v work
to do that because we have to
copy all the existing edges
over to this new array
and then add this new edge
to the end of that array.
Of course, you could
amortize this cost
across multiple updates.
So if you run out
of memory, you can
double the size of
your array so you
don't have to create these
new arrays too often.
But the cost for any
individual addition
is still relatively expensive
compared to, say, an edge list
or adjacency matrix.
And then finally, for the
compressed sparse row format,
if you add an edge,
in the worst case,
it's going to cost us
order m plus n work.
Because we're going to have to
reconstruct the entire Offsets
array and the entire Edges
array in the worst case.
Because we have to put
something in and then
shift-- in the Edges
array, you have
to put something in and
shift all of the values
to the right of that
over by one location.
And then for the
Offsets array, we
have to modify the offset for
the particular vertex we're
adding an edge to and
then the offsets for all
of the vertices after that.
So the compressed sparse
row representation
is not particularly
friendly to edge updates.
What about for deleting an
edge from some vertex v?
So for adjacency
matrix, again, it's
going to be constant
time because you just
randomly access
the correct entry
and flip the bit from 1 to 0.
What about for an edge list?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so for an
edge list, in the worst case,
it's going to cost us order m
work because the edges are not
in any sorted order.
So we have to scan through the
whole thing in the worst case
to find the edge that
we're trying to delete.
For adjacency list, it's going
to take order degree of v work
because the neighbors
are not sorted.
So we have to scan
through the whole thing
to find this edge that
we're trying to delete.
And then finally, for a
compressed sparse row,
it's going to be order
m plus n because we're
going to have to reconstruct the
whole thing in the worst case.
What about finding
all of the neighbors
of a particular vertex v?
What's the cost of doing
this in the adjacency matrix?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, so
it's going to cost us
order n work to find
all the neighbors
of a particular
vertex because we just
scan the correct row
in this matrix, the row
corresponding to vertex
v. For the edge list,
we're going to have to
scan the entire edge
list because it's not sorted.
So in the worst case,
that's going to be order m.
For adjacency list, that's
going to take order degree of v
because we can just find
a pointer to the linked
list for that vertex
in constant time.
And then we just traverse
over the linked list.
And that takes order
degree of v time.
And then finally, for
compressed sparse row format,
it's also order degree of v
because we have constant time
access into the appropriate
location in the Edges array.
And then we can just
read off the edges, which
are consecutive in memory.
So what about finding if a
vertex w is a neighbor of v?
So I'll just give
you the answer.
So for the adjacency
matrix, it's
going to take constant
time because again,
we just have to check the
v-th row in the w-th column
and check if the
bit is set there.
For edge list, we have to
traverse the entire list
to see if the edge is there.
And then for adjacency list
and compressed sparse row,
it's going to be
order degree of v
because we just have to scan the
neighbor list for that vertex.
So these are some
graph representations.
But there are actually many
other graph representations,
including variance of the ones
that I've talked about here.
So, for example,
for the adjacency,
I said you can either use
a linked list or an array
to store the neighbor list.
But you can actually use
a hybrid approach, where
you store the linked list, but
each linked list node actually
stores more than one vertex.
So you can store
maybe 16 vertices
in each linked list node.
And that gives us
better cache locality.
So for the rest of
this lecture, I'm
going to talk about
algorithms that
are best implemented using the
compressed sparse row format.
And this is because
we're going to be
dealing with sparse graphs.
We're going to be looking at
static algorithms, where we
don't have to update the graph.
If we do have to
update the graph,
then CSR isn't a good choice.
But we're just going to be
looking at static algorithms
today.
And then for all the algorithms
that we'll be looking at,
we're going to need to scan over
all the neighbors of a vertex
that we visit.
And CSR is very good
for that because all
of the neighbors for
a particular vertex
are stored
contiguously in memory.
So any questions so far?
OK, I do want to talk
about some properties
of real-world graphs.
So first, we're seeing graphs
that are quite large today.
But actually, they're
not too large.
So here are the sizes of
some of the real-world graphs
out there.
So there is a Twitter network.
That's actually a snapshot
of the Twitter network
from a couple of years ago.
It has 41 million vertices
and 1.5 billion edges.
And you can store this graph in
about 6.3 gigabytes of memory.
So you can probably store it in
the main memory of your laptop.
The largest publicly
available graph out
there now is this
Common Crawl web graph.
It has 3.5 billion vertices
and 128 billion edges.
So storing this graph
requires a little
over 1/2 terabyte of memory.
It is quite a bit of memory.
But it's actually not too big
because there are machines out
there with main memory sizes
in the order of terabytes
of memory nowadays.
So, for example, you can rent
2-terabyte or 4-terabyte memory
instance on AWS, which you're
using for your homework
assignments.
See if you have any
leftover credits
at the end of the
semester, and you
want to play around
on this graph,
you can rent one of
these terabyte machines.
Just remember to
turn it off when
you're done because
it's kind of expensive.
Another property of
real-world graphs
is that they're quite sparse.
So m tends to be much
less than n squared.
So most of the possible
edges are not actually there.
And finally, the degree
distributions of the vertices
can be highly skewed in
many real-world graphs.
So here I'm plotting
the degree on the x-axis
and the number of vertices
with that particular degree
on the y-axis.
And we can see that
it's highly skewed.
And, for example, in a social
network, most of the people
would be on the left-hand
side, so their degree is not
that high.
And then we have some
very popular people
on the right-hand side, where
their degree is very high,
but we don't have
too many of those.
So this is what's known as a
power law degree distribution.
And there have been
various studies
that have shown that many
real-world graphs have
approximately a power
law degree distribution.
And mathematically, this
means that the number
of vertices with degree
d is proportional to d
to the negative p.
So negative p is the exponent.
And for many graphs, the value
of p lies between 2 and 3.
And this power law
degree distribution
does have implications
when we're
trying to implement parallel
algorithms to process
these graphs.
Because with graphs that have
a skewed degree distribution,
you could run into load
and balance issues.
If you just parallelize
across the vertices,
the number of edges they
have can vary significantly.
Any questions?
OK, so now let's talk about
how we can implement a graph
algorithm.
And I'm going to talk about the
breadth-first search algorithm.
So how many of you have seen
breadth-first search before?
OK, so about half of you.
I did talk about breadth-first
search in a previous lecture,
so I was hoping everybody
would raise their hands.
OK, so as a reminder,
in the BFS algorithm,
we're given a source
vertex s, and we
want to visit the vertices
in order of their distance
from the source s.
And there are many
possible outputs
that we might care about.
One possible output
is, we just want
to report the
vertices in the order
that they were visited by the
breadth-first search traversal.
So let's say we have
this graph here.
And our source vertex
is D. So what's
one possible order in which we
can traverse these vertices?
Now, I should specify
that we should
traverse this graph in a
breadth-first search manner.
So what's the first vertex
we're going to explore?
AUDIENCE: D.
JULIAN SHUN: D. So
we're first going
to look at D because
that's our source vertex.
The second vertex,
we can actually
choose between B, C, and E
because all we care about
is that we're visiting
these vertices
in the order of their
distance from the source.
But these three vertices are
all of the same distance.
So let's just pick
B, C, and then E.
And then finally,
I'm going to visit
vertex A, which has a
distance of 2 from the source.
So this is one
possible solution.
There are other
possible solutions
because we could have visited E
before we visited B and so on.
Another possible output
that we might care about
is we might want to report
the distance from each vertex
to the source vertex s.
So in this example
here are the distances.
So D has a distance of 0; B,C,
and E all have a distance of 1;
and A has a distance of 2.
We might also want to generate a
breadth-first search tree where
each vertex in the
tree has a parent which
is a neighbor in
the previous level
of the breadth-first search.
Or in other words,
the parent should
have a distance of 1 less
than that vertex itself.
So here's an example of a
breadth-first search tree.
And we can see that
each of the vertices
has a parent whose breadth-first
search distance is 1 less
than itself.
So the algorithms that I'm
going to be talking about today
will generate the distances
as well as the BFS tree.
And BFS actually has
many applications.
So it's used as a
subroutine in betweenness
centrality, which is a
very popular graph mining
algorithm used to rank
the importance of nodes
in a network.
And the importance of
nodes here corresponds
to how many shortest paths
go through that node.
Other applications include
eccentricity estimation,
maximum flows.
Some max flow algorithms
use BFS as a subroutine.
You can use BFS
to crawl the web,
do cycle detection, garbage
collection, and so on.
So let's now look at a
serial BFS algorithm.
And here, I'm just going
to show the pseudocode.
So first, we're going to
initialize the distances
to all INFINITY.
And we're going to initialize
the parents to be NIL.
And then we're going to
create queue data structure.
We're going to set the
distance of the root
to be 0 because the root has
a distance of 0 to itself.
And then we're going to place
the root onto this queue.
And then, while the
queue is not empty,
we're going to dequeue the
first thing in the queue.
We're going to look at all the
neighbors of the current vertex
that we dequeued.
And for each
neighbor, we're going
to check if its
distance is INFINITY.
If the distance
is INFINITY, that
means we haven't explored
that neighbor yet.
So we're going to go
ahead and explore it.
And we do so by setting
its distance value
to be the current
vertex's distance plus 1.
We're going to set the
parent of that neighbor
to be the current vertex.
And then we'll place the
neighbor onto the queue.
So it's some pretty
simple algorithm.
And we're just going to keep
iterating in this while loop
until there are no more
vertices left in the queue.
So what's the work of this
algorithm in terms of n and m?
So how much work are
we doing per edge?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so assuming
that the enqueue and dequeue
operators are
constant time, then
we're doing constant
amount of work per edge.
So summed across all edges,
that's going to be order m.
And then we're also
doing a constant amount
of work per vertex because
we have to basically place it
onto the queue and then
take it off the queue,
and then also
initialize their value.
So the overall work is
going to be order m plus n.
OK, so let's now look
at some actual code
to implement the serial
BFS algorithm using
the compressed
sparse row format.
So first, I'm going to
initialize two arrays--
parent and queue.
And these are going to be
integer arrays of size n.
I'm going to initialize
all of the parent entries
to be negative 1.
I'm going to place a source
vertex onto the queue.
So it's going to appear
at queue of 0, that's
the beginning of the queue.
And then I'll set the
parent of the source vertex
to be the source itself.
And then I also
have two integers
that point to the front
and the back of the queue.
So initially, the front of
the queue is at position 0,
and the back is at position 1.
And then while the
queue is not empty--
and I can check that by
checking if q_front is not
equal to q_back--
then I'm going to dequeue
the first vertex in my queue.
I'm going to set current
to be that vertex.
And then I'll increment q_front.
And then I'll compute the
degree of that vertex, which
I can do by looking
at the difference
between consecutive offsets.
And I also assume
that Offsets of n
is equal to m, just to
deal with the last vertex
And then I'm going to loop
through all of the neighbors
for the current vertex.
And to access each
neighbor, what I do
is I go into the Edges array.
And I know that my neighbors
start at Offsets of current.
And therefore, to get
the i-th neighbor,
I just do Offsets
of current plus i.
That's my index into
the Edges array.
Now I'm going to check if my
neighbor has been explored yet.
And I can check that by
checking if parent of neighbor
is equal to negative 1.
If it is, that means I
haven't explored it yet.
And then I'll set a parent
of neighbor to be current.
And then I'll place the neighbor
onto the back of the queue
and increment q_back.
And I'm just going to keep
repeating this while loop
until it becomes empty.
And here, I'm only generating
the parent pointers.
But I could also
generate the distances
if I wanted to with just
a slight modification
of this code.
So any questions on
how this code works?
OK, so here's a question.
What's the most expensive
part of the code?
Can you point to one
particular line here
that is the most expensive?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to guess the
[INAUDIBLE] that's gonna be all
over the place in terms
of memory locations--
ngh equals Edges.
JULIAN SHUN: OK, so
actually, it turns out
that that's not the most
expensive part of this code.
But you're close.
So anyone have any other ideas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it looking
up the parent array?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, so it turns
out that this line here,
where we're accessing
parent of neighbor,
that turns out to be
the most expensive.
Because whenever we
access this parent array,
the neighbor can appear
anywhere in memory.
So that's going to
be a random access.
And if the parent array
doesn't fit in our cache,
then that's going to cost us a
cache miss almost every time.
This Edges array is actually
mostly accessed sequentially.
Because for each
vertex, all of its edges
are stored
contiguously in memory,
we do have one random access
into the Edges array per vertex
because we have to look
up the starting location
for that vertex.
But it's not 1 per edge, unlike
this check of the parent array.
That occurs for every edge.
So does that make sense?
So let's do a
back-of-the-envelope
calculation to figure out how
many cache misses we would
incur, assuming that we
started with a cold cache.
And we also assume
that n is much larger
than the size of the
cache, so we can't fit
any of these arrays into cache.
We'll assume that a
cache line has 64 bytes,
and integers are 4 bytes each.
So let's try to analyze this.
So the initialization will
cost us n/16 cache misses.
And the reason here is that
we're initializing this array
sequentially.
So we're accessing
contiguous locations.
And this can take advantage
of spatial locality.
On each cache line, we can
fit 16 of the integers.
So overall, we're going to
need n/16 cache misses just
to initialize this array.
We also need n/16 cache misses
across the entire algorithm
to dequeue the vertex from
the front of the queue.
Because again, this is going
to be a sequential access
into this queue array.
And across all vertices,
that's going to be n/16
cache misses because we can fit
16 integers on a cache line.
To compute the
degree here, that's
going to take n
cache misses overall.
Because each of these
accesses to Offsets
array is going to
be a random access.
Because we have no idea what
the value of current here is.
It could be anything.
So across the entire
algorithm, we're
going to need n cache misses
to access this Offsets array.
And then to access
this Edges array,
I claim that we're going to
need at most 2n plus m/16 cache
misses.
So does anyone see where
that bound comes from?
So where does the
m/16 come from?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have to access
that at least once for an edge.
JULIAN SHUN: Right, so you
have to pay m/16 because you're
accessing every edge once.
And you're accessing
the Edges contiguously.
So therefore, across
all Edges, that's
going to take m/16 cache misses.
But we also have to add 2n.
Because whenever we access the
Edges for a particular vertex,
the first cache
line might not only
contain that vertex's edges.
And similarly, the
last cache line
that we access might
also not just contain
that vertex's edges.
So therefore, we're going
to waste the first cache
line and the last cache line in
the worst case for each vertex.
And summed cross all vertices,
that's going to be 2n.
So this is the upper
bound, 2n plus m/16.
Accessing this
parent array, that's
going to be a random
access every time.
So we're going to
incur a cache miss
in the worst case every time.
So summed across
all edge accesses,
that's going to
be m cache misses.
And then finally,
we're going to pay
n/16 cache misses to enqueue
the neighbor onto the queue
because these are
sequential accesses.
So in total, we're going
to incur at most 51/16 n
plus 17/16 16 m cache misses.
And if m is greater than
3n, then the second term
here is going to dominate.
And m is usually greater than
3n in most real-world graphs.
And the second term here is
dominated by this random access
into the parent array.
So let's see if we can
optimize this code so that we
get better cache performance.
So let's say we could fit a bit
vector of size n into cache.
But we couldn't fit the entire
parent array into cache.
What can we do to reduce
the number of cache misses?
So does anyone have any ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is bitvector
to keep track of which
vertices of other
parents then [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
that's exactly correct.
So we're going to
use a bit vector
to store whether the vertex
has been explored yet or not.
So we only need 1 bit for that.
We're not storing the parent
ID in this bit vector.
We're just storing a bit to
say whether that vertex has
been explored yet or not.
And then, before we
check this parent array,
we're going to first
check the bit vector
to see if that vertex
has been explored yet.
And if it has been
explored yet, we
don't even need to
access this parent array.
If it hasn't been
explored, then we
won't go ahead and access the
parent entry of the neighbor.
But we only have
to do this one time
for each vertex in the
graph because we can only
visit each vertex once.
And therefore, we can
reduce the number of cache
misses from m down to n.
So overall, this might improve
the number of cache misses.
In fact, it does if
the number of edges
is large enough relative
to the number of vertices.
However, you do have to do a
little bit more computation
because you have to do bit
vector manipulation to check
this bit vector and then also
to set the bit vector when
you explore a neighbor.
So here's the code using
the bit vector optimization.
So here, I'm initializing this
bit vector called visited.
It's of size,
approximately, n/32.
And then I'm setting
all of the bits
to 0, except for the
source vertex, where
I'm going to set its bit to 1.
And I'm doing this
bit calculation here
to figure out the bit
for the source vertex.
And then now, when I'm
trying to visit a neighbor,
I'm first going to check
if the neighbor is visited
by checking this bit array.
And I can do this using
this computation here--
AND visited of neighbor
over 32, by this mask--
1 left shifted by
neighbor mod 32.
And if that's false,
that means the neighbor
hasn't been visited yet.
So I'll go inside
this IF clause.
And then I'll set
the visited bit
to be true using
this statement here.
And then I do the same
operations as I did before.
It turns out that
this version is
faster for large
enough values of m
relative to n because you
reduce the number of cache
misses overall.
You still have to do this
extra computation here,
this bit manipulation.
But if m is large enough,
then the reduction
in number of cache
misses outweighs
the additional computation
that you have to do.
Any questions?
OK, so that was a
serial implementation
of breadth-first search.
Now let's look at a
parallel implementation.
So I'm first going
to do an animation
of how a parallel breadth-first
search algorithm would work.
The parallel reference
search algorithm
is going to operate
on frontiers,
where the initial frontier
contains just a source vertex.
And on every
iteration, I'm going
to explore all of the
vertices on the frontier
and then place any
unexplored neighbors
onto the next frontier.
And then I move on
to the next frontier.
So in the first
iteration, I'm going
to mark the source
vertex as explored,
set its distance to
be 0, and then place
the neighbors of that source
vertex onto the next frontier.
In the next iteration, I'm
going to do the same thing, set
these distances to 1.
I also am going to
generate a parent pointer
for each of these vertices.
And this parent should come
from the previous frontier,
and it should be a
neighbor of the vertex.
And here, there's
only one option,
which is the source vertex.
So I'll just pick
that as the parent.
And then I'm going to
place the neighbors
onto the next frontier again,
mark those as explored,
set their distances,
and generate a parent
pointer again.
And notice here, when I'm
generating these parent
pointers, there's actually
more than one choice
for some of these vertices.
And this is because there
are multiple vertices
on the previous frontier.
And some of them explored
the same neighbor
on the current frontier.
So a parallel
implementation has to be
aware of this potential race.
Here, I'm just picking
an arbitrary parent.
So as we see here,
you can process each
of these frontiers in parallel.
So you can parallelize over all
of the vertices on the frontier
as well as all of
their outgoing edges.
However, you do need to
process one frontier before you
move on to the next one
in this BFS algorithm.
And a parallel
implementation has
to be aware of potential races.
So as I said earlier, we
could have multiple vertices
on the frontier trying to
visit the same neighbors.
So somehow, that
has to be resolved.
And also, the amount of
work on each frontier
is changing throughout the
course of the algorithm.
So you have to be careful
with load balancing.
Because you have to make
sure that the amount of work
each processor has to
do is about the same.
If you use Cilk
to implement this,
then load balancing doesn't
really become a problem.
So any questions on
the BFS algorithm
before I go over the code?
OK, so here's the actual code.
And here I'm going to
initialize these four arrays, so
the parent array, which
is the same as before.
I'm going to have an array
called frontier, which
stores the current frontier.
And then I'm going
to have an array
called frontierNext,
which is a temporary array
that I use to store the
next frontier of the BFS.
And then also I have an
array called degrees.
I'm going to initialize
all of the parent entries
to be negative 1.
I do that using a cilk_for loop.
I'm going to place the source
vertex at the 0-th index
of the frontier.
I'll set the
frontierSize to be 1.
And then I set the parent of the
source to be the source itself.
While the frontierSize
is greater than 0,
that means I still
have more work to do.
I'm going to first
iterate over all
of the vertices on my frontier
in parallel using a cilk_for
loop.
And then I'll set the i-th
entry of the degrees array
to be the degree of the
i-th vertex on the frontier.
And I can do this just
using the difference
between consecutive offsets.
And then I'm going to perform
a prefix sum on this degrees
array.
And we'll see in a minute why
I'm doing this prefix sum.
But first of all, does anybody
recall what prefix sum is?
So who knows what prefix sum is?
Do you want to
tell us what it is?
AUDIENCE: That's the sum array
where index i is the sum of
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so prefix sum--
so here I'm going to demonstrate
this with an example.
So let's say this
is our input array.
The output of this array
would store for each location
the sum of everything before
that location in the input
array.
So here we see that the first
position has a value of 0
because a sum of
everything before it is 0.
There's nothing before
it in the input.
The second position
has a value of 2
because the sum of
everything before it is just
the first location.
The third location
has a value of 6
because the sum of
everything before it is 2
plus 4, which is 6, and so on.
So I believe this was on one
of your homework assignments.
So hopefully, everyone
knows what prefix sum is.
And later on, we'll
see how we use
this to do the parallel
breadth-first search.
OK, so I'm going to do a prefix
sum on this degrees array.
And then I'm going to loop over
my frontier again in parallel.
I'm going to let v be the
i-th vertex on the frontier.
Index is going to be
equal to degrees of i.
And then my degree is
going to be Offsets of v
plus 1 minus Offsets of v.
Now I'm going to loop
through all v's neighbors.
And here I just have
a serial for loop.
But you could actually
parallelize this for loop.
It turns out that if the number
of iterations in the for loop
is small enough, there's
additional overhead
to making this parallel, so I
just made it serial for now.
But you could make it parallel.
To get the neighbor, I just
index into this Edges array.
I look at Offsets of v plus j.
Then now I'm going to
check if the neighbor has
been explored yet.
And I can check if
parent of neighbor
is equal to negative 1.
So that means it hasn't
been explored yet, so I'm
going to try to explore it.
And I do so using
a compare-and-swap.
I'm going to try to
swap in the value of v
with the original
value of negative 1
in parent of neighbor.
And the compare-and-swap
is going
to return true if it was
successful and false otherwise.
And if it returns
true, that means
this vertex becomes the
parent of this neighbor.
And then I'll place
the neighbor on
to frontierNext at
this particular index--
index plus j.
And otherwise, I'll set a
negative 1 at that location.
OK, so let's see why I'm
using index plus j here.
So here's how
frontierNext is organized.
So each vertex on
the frontier owns
a subset of these locations
in the frontierNext array.
And these are all
contiguous memory locations.
And it turns out that
the starting location
for each of these vertices
in this frontierNext array
is exactly the value in this
prefix sum array up here.
So vertex 1 has its first
location at index 0.
Vertex 2 has its first
location at index 2.
Vertex 3 has its first
location at index 6, and so on.
So by using a prefix
sum, I can guarantee
that all of these vertices
have a disjoint subarray
in this frontierNext array.
And then they can all write
to this frontierNext array
in parallel without any races.
And index plus j just
gives us the right location
to write to in this array.
So index is the
starting location,
and then j is for
the j-th neighbor.
So here is one potential
output after we write
to this frontierNext array.
So we have some
non-negative values.
And these are vertices that
we explored in this iteration.
We also have some
negative 1 values.
And the negative 1 here means
that either the vertex has
already been explored
in a previous iteration,
or we tried to explore it
in the current iteration,
but somebody else
got there before us.
Because somebody else is
doing the compare-and-swap
at the same time, and they could
have finished before we did,
so we failed on the
compare-and-swap.
So we don't actually want these
negative 1 values, so we're
going to filter them out.
And we can filter them out
using a prefix sum again.
And this is going to
give us a new frontier.
And we'll set the
frontierSize equal to the size
of this new frontier.
And then we repeat
this while loop
until there are no more
vertices on the frontier.
So any questions on this
parallel BFS algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you go over
like the last [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Do you
mean the filter out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so what you can do
is, you can create another
array, which stores a 1
in location i if that location
is not a negative 1 and 0
if it is a negative 1.
Then you do a prefix
sum on that array,
which gives us unique
offsets into an output array.
So then everybody just looks
at the prefix sum array there.
And then it writes
to the output array.
So it might be easier if I
tried to draw this on the board.
OK, so let's say we have
an array of size 5 here.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to generate another
array which stores
a 1 if the value in the
corresponding location
is not a negative
1 and 0 otherwise.
And then I do a prefix
sum on this array here.
And this gives me
0, 1, 1, 2, and 2.
And now each of these values
that are not negative 1,
they can just look up
the corresponding index
in this output array.
And this gives us a unique
index into an output array.
So this element will
write to position 0,
this element would
write to position 1,
and this element would write to
position 2 in my final output.
So this would be
my final frontier.
Does that make sense?
OK, so let's now
analyze the working span
of this parallel BFS algorithm.
So a number of iterations
required by the BFS algorithm
is upper-bounded by the
diameter D of the graph.
And the diameter of a graph
is just the maximum shortest
path between any pair of
vertices in the graph.
And that's an upper bound
on the number of iterations
we need to do.
Each iteration is
going to take a log m
span for the clik_for loops,
the prefix sum, and the filter.
And this is also assuming
that the inner loop
is parallelized, the inner loop
over the neighbors of a vertex.
So to get the span, we just
multiply these two terms.
So we get theta of
D times log m span.
What about the work?
So to compute the work,
we have to figure out
how much work we're doing
per vertex and per edge.
So first, notice that
the sum of the frontier
sizes across entire
algorithm is going
to be n because each vertex
can be on the frontier at most
once.
Also, each edge is going to
be traversed exactly once.
So that leads to m
total edge visits.
On each iteration
of the algorithm,
we're doing a prefix sum.
And the cost of
this prefix sum is
going to be proportional
to the frontier size.
So summed across all iterations,
the cost of the prefix
sum is going to be theta of n.
We also have to do this filter.
But the work of the filter
is proportional to the number
of edges traversed
in that iteration.
And summed across all
iterations, that's
going to give theta of m total.
So overall, the
work is going to be
theta of n plus m for this
parallel BFS algorithm.
So this is a
work-efficient algorithm.
The work matches out
the serial algorithm.
Any questions on the analysis?
OK, so let's look at
how this parallel BFS
algorithm runs in practice.
So here, I ran some
experiments on a random graph
with 10 million vertices
and 100 million edges.
And the edges were
randomly generated.
And I made sure that
each vertex had 10 edges.
I ran experiments
on a 40-core machine
with 2-way hyperthreading.
Does anyone know what
hyperthreading is?
Yeah, what is it?
AUDIENCE: It's when you
have like one CPU core that
can execute two instruction
screens at the same time
so it can [INAUDIBLE]
high number latency.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
that's a great answer.
So hyperthreading is
an Intel technology
where for each physical core,
the operating system actually
sees it as two logical cores.
They share many of
the same resources,
but they have their
own registers.
So if one of the logical
cores stalls on a long latency
operation, the
other logical core
can use the shared resources
and hide some of the latency.
OK, so here I am
plotting the speedup
over the single-threaded time
of the parallel algorithm
versus the number of threads.
So we see that on
40 threads, we get
a speedup of about 22 or 23X.
And when we turn
on hyperthreading
and use all 80 threads, the
speedup is about 32 times
on 40 cores.
And this is actually pretty good
for a parallel graph algorithm.
It's very hard to get
very good speedups
on these irregular
graph algorithms.
So 32X on 40 cores
is pretty good.
I also compared this to
the serial BFS algorithm
because that's
what we ultimately
want to compare against.
So we see that on 80 threads,
the speedup over the serial BFS
is about 21, 22X.
And the serial BFS is 54%
faster than the parallel BFS
on one thread.
This is because it's doing less
work than the parallel version.
The parallel version has to
do actual work with the prefix
sum in the filter, whereas
the serial version doesn't
have to do that.
But overall, the
parallel implementation
is still pretty good.
OK, questions?
So a couple of lectures
ago, we saw this slide here.
So Charles told
us never to write
nondeterministic parallel
programs because it's
very hard to debug these
programs and hard to reason
about them.
So is there nondeterminism
in this BFS code
that we looked at?
AUDIENCE: You have
nondeterminism
in the compare-and-swap.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so
there's nondeterminism
in the compare-and-swap.
So let's go back to the code.
So this compare-and-swap
here, there's
a race there because we get
multiple vertices trying
to write to the parent entry of
the neighbor at the same time.
And the one that wins
is nondeterministic.
So the BFS tree that you get
at the end is nondeterministic.
OK, so let's see how we can
try to fix this nondeterminism.
OK so, as we said,
this is a line
that causes the nondeterminism.
It turns out that we can
actually make the output BFS
tree, be deterministic
by going over
the outgoing edges in each
iteration in two phases.
So how this works is
that in the first phase,
the vertices on the
frontier are not actually
going to write to
the parent array.
Or they are going to
write, but they're
going to be using this
writeMin operator.
And the writeMin operator
is an atomic operation
that guarantees that we
have concurrent writes
to the same location.
The smallest value
gets written there.
So the value that
gets written there
is going to be deterministic.
It's always going
to be the smallest
one that tries to write there.
Then in the second
phase, each vertex
is going to check
for each neighbor
whether a parent of neighbor
is equal to v. If it is,
that means it was the vertex
that successfully wrote
to parent of neighbor
in the first phase.
And therefore, it's going to
be responsible for placing
this neighbor onto
the next frontier.
And we're also going to
set parent of neighbor
to be negative v. This
is just a minor detail.
And this is because when we're
doing this writeMin operator,
we could have a future iteration
where a lower vertex tries
to visit the same vertex
that we already explored.
But if we set this
to a negative value,
we're only going to be
writing non-negative values
to this location.
So the writeMin on a neighbor
that has already been explored
would never succeed.
OK, so the final BFS tree
that's generated by this code
is always going to be the
same every time you run it.
I want to point out
that this code is still
notdeterministic with
respect to the order
in which individual memory
locations get updated.
So you still have a
deterministic race here
in the writeMin operator.
But it's still better than
a nondeterministic code
in that you always
get the same BFS tree.
So how do you actually implement
the writeMin operation?
So it turns out you can
implement this using
a loop with a compare-and-swap.
So writeMin takes as
input two arguments--
the memory address that
we're trying to update
and the new value that we
want to write to that address.
We're first going to set
oldval equal to the value
at that memory address.
And we're going to check if
newval is less than oldval.
If it is, then we're
going to attempt
to do a compare-and-swap
at that location,
writing newval into that
address if its initial value
was oldval.
And if that succeeds,
then we return.
Otherwise, we failed.
And that means that somebody
else came in the meantime
and changed the value there.
And therefore, we have
to reread the old value
at the memory address.
And then we repeat.
And there are two ways that this
writeMin operator could finish.
One is if the compare-and-swap
was successful.
The other one is if
newval is greater than
or equal to oldval.
In that case, we no longer
have to try to write anymore
because the value that's there
is already smaller than what
we're trying to write.
So I implemented an
optimized version
of this deterministic
parallel BFS code
and compared it to the
nondeterministic version.
And it turns out
on 32 cores, it's
only a little bit slower than
the nondeterministic version.
So it's about 5% to 20% slower
on a range of different input
graphs.
So this is a pretty small
price to pay for determinism.
And you get many nice
benefits, such as ease
of debugging and ease of
reasoning about the performance
of your code.
Any questions?
OK, so let me talk about
another optimization
for breadth-first search.
And this is called the
direction optimization.
And the idea is motivated by
how the sizes of the frontiers
change in a typical BFS
algorithm over time.
So here I'm plotting
the frontier size
on the y-axis in log scale.
And the x-axis is
the iteration number.
And on the left, we have a
random graph, on the right,
we have a parallel graph.
And we see that the
frontier size actually
grows pretty rapidly, especially
for the power law graph.
And then it drops
pretty rapidly.
So this is true for many
of the real-world graphs
that we see because many of
them look like power law graphs.
And in the BFS algorithm,
most of the work
is done when the frontier
is relatively large.
So most of the
work is going to be
done in these middle
iterations where
the frontier is very large.
And it turns out that
there are two ways
to do breadth-first search.
One way is the
traditional way, which
I'm going to refer to
as the top-down method.
And this is just
what we did before.
We look at the
frontier vertices,
and explore all of their
outgoing neighbors,
and mark any of the
unexplored ones as explored,
and place them on to
the next frontier.
But there's actually another
way to do breadth-first search.
And this is known as
the bottom-up method.
And in the bottom-up
method, I'm going
to look at all of the
vertices in the graph that
haven't been
explored yet, and I'm
going to look at
their incoming edges.
And if I find an incoming edge
that's on the current frontier,
I can just say that that
incoming neighbor is my parent.
And I don't even need
to look at the rest
of my incoming neighbors.
So in this example here,
vertices 9 through 12,
when they loop through
their incoming edges,
they found incoming
neighbor on the frontier,
and they chose that
neighbor as their parent.
And they get marked as explored.
And we can actually save some
edge traversals here because,
for example, if you
look at vertex 9,
and you imagine the
edges being traversed
in a top-to-bottom manner,
then vertex 9 is only
going to look at its
first incoming edge
and find the incoming
neighbors on the frontier.
So it doesn't even
need to inspect
the rest of the incoming
edges because all
we care about finding is just
one parent in the BFS tree.
We don't need to find all
of the possible parents.
In this example here, vertices
13 through 15 actually ended up
wasting work because they looked
at all of their incoming edges.
And none of the incoming
neighbors are on the frontier.
So they don't actually
find a neighbor.
So the bottom-up
approach turns out
to work pretty well when
the frontier is large
and many vertices have
been already explored.
Because in this case, you don't
have to look at many vertices.
And for the ones
that you do look at,
when you scan over
their incoming edges,
it's very likely
that early on, you'll
find a neighbor that is
on the current frontier,
and you can skip a bunch
of edge traversals.
And the top-down
approach is better
when the frontier
is relatively small.
And in a paper by
Scott Beamer in 2012,
he actually studied
the performance
of these two approaches in BFS.
And this plot here
plots the running time
versus the iteration number
for a power law graph
and compares the performance
of the top-down and bottom-up
approach.
So we see that for
the first two steps,
the top-down approach is faster
than the bottom-up approach.
But then for the
next couple of steps,
the bottom-up approach is
faster than a top-down approach.
And then when we get to the
end, the top-down approach
becomes faster again.
So the top-down
approach, as I said,
is more efficient
for small frontiers,
whereas a bottom-up
approach is more
efficient for large frontiers.
Also, I want to point out that
in the top-down approach, when
we update the parent array,
that actually has to be atomic.
Because we can have
multiple vertices trying
to update the same neighbor.
But in a bottom-up approach,
the update to the parent array
doesn't have to be atomic.
Because we're scanning
over the incoming neighbors
of any particular
vertex v serially.
And therefore, there can
only be one processor
that's writing to parent of v.
So we choose between
these two approaches based
on the size of the frontier.
We found that a threshold of
a frontier size of about n/20
works pretty well in practice.
So if the frontier has
more than n/20 vertices,
we used a bottom up approach.
And otherwise, we used
a top-down approach.
You can also use more
sophisticated thresholds,
such as also considering
the sum of out-degrees,
since the actual work
is dependent on the sum
of out-degrees of the
vertices on the frontier.
You can also use
different thresholds
for going from top-down
to bottom-up and then
another threshold for going
from bottom-up back to top-down.
And in fact, that's what
the original paper did.
They had two
different thresholds.
We also need to generate
the inverse graph
or the transposed graph
if we're using this method
if the graph is directed.
Because if the
graph is directed,
in the bottom-up
approach, we actually
need to look at the
incoming neighbors, not
the outgoing neighbors.
So if the graph wasn't
already symmetrized,
then we have to generate
both the incoming neighbors
and outgoing neighbors
for each vertex.
So we can do that as
a pre-processing step.
Any questions?
OK, so how do we actually
represent the frontier?
So one way to
represent the frontier
is just use a sparse
integer array,
which is what we did before.
Another way to do this
is to use a dense array.
So, for example, here I
have an array of bytes.
The array is of size n, where
n is the number of vertices.
And I have a 1 in
position i if vertex i
is on the frontier
and 0 otherwise.
I can also use a bit vector
to further compress this
and then use additional bit
level operations to access it.
So for the top-down approach,
a sparse representation
is better because the
top-down approach usually
deals with small frontiers.
And if we use a
sparse array, we only
have to do work proportional
to the number of vertices
on the frontier.
And then in the
bottom-up approach,
it turns out that dense
representation is better
because we're looking at
most of the vertices anyways.
And then we need to switch
between these two methods based
on the approach
that we're using.
So here's some performance
numbers comparing the three
different modes of traversal.
So we have bottom-up,
top-down, and then
the direction
optimizing approach
using a threshold of n/20.
First of all, we see that
the bottom-up approach
is the slowest for
both of these graphs.
And this is because it's
doing a lot of wasted work
in the early iterations.
We also see that the direction
optimizing approach is always
faster than both the top-down
and the bottom-up approach.
This is because if we switch
to the bottom-up approach
at an appropriate
time, then we can
save a lot of edge traversals.
And, for example, you can
see for the power law graph,
the direction
optimizing approach
is almost three times faster
than the top-down approach.
The benefits of this
approach are highly
dependent on the input graph.
So it works very well for
power law and random graphs.
But if you have graphs where the
frontier size is always small,
such as a grid graph
or a road network,
then you would never use
a bottom-up approach.
So this wouldn't actually give
you any performance gains.
Any questions?
So it turns out that
this direction optimizing
idea is more general than
just breadth-first search.
So a couple years
ago, I developed
this framework called
Ligra, where I generalized
the direction optimizing idea
to other graph algorithms,
such as betweenness centrality,
connected components, sparse
PageRank, shortest
paths, and so on.
And in the Ligra framework,
we have an EDGEMAP operator
that chooses between a
sparse implementation
and a dense implementation based
on the size of the frontier.
So the sparse here corresponds
to the top-down approach.
And dense corresponds to
the bottom-up approach.
And it turns out that using
this direction optimizing
idea for these
other applications
also gives you performance
gains in practice.
OK, so let me now talk about
another optimization, which
is graph compression.
And the goal here is to reduce
the amount of memory usage
in the graph algorithm.
So recall, this was
our CSR representation.
And in the Edges
array, we just stored
the values of the target edges.
Instead of storing
the actual targets,
we can actually do better by
first sorting the edges so
that they appear in
non-decreasing order
and then just storing
the differences
between consecutive edges.
And then for the first edge
for any particular vertex,
we'll store the difference
between the target
and the source of that edge.
So, for example,
here, for vertex 0,
the first edge is going
to have a value of 2
because we're going to take the
difference between the target
and the source.
So 2 minus 0 is 2.
Then for the next
edge, we're going
to take the difference
between the second edge
and the first edge, so
7 minus 2, which is 5.
And then similarly we do that
for all of the remaining edges.
Notice that there are
some negative values here.
And this is because the target
is smaller than the source.
So in this example,
1 is smaller than 2.
So if you do 1 minus
2, you get a negative--
negative 1.
And this can only happen
for the first edge
for any particular
vertex because for all
the other edges, we're
encoding the difference
between that edge and
the previous edge.
And we already
sorted these edges
so that they appear in
non-decreasing order.
OK, so this
compressed edges array
will typically
contain smaller values
than this original edges array.
So now we want to be
able to use fewer bits
to represent these values.
We don't want to use 32 or
64 bits like we did before.
Otherwise, we wouldn't
be saving any space.
So one way to reduce
the space usage
is to store these values using
what's called a variable length
code or a k-bit code.
And the idea is to encode each
value in chunks of k bits,
where for each chunk, we use k
minus 1 bits for the data and 1
bit as the continue bit.
So for example, let's
encode the integer 401
using 8-bit or byte codes.
So first, we're going to write
this value out in binary.
And then we're going to
take the bottom 7 bits,
and we're going to
place that into the data
field of the first chunk.
And then in the last
bit of this chunk,
we're going to check if
we still have any more
bits that we need to encode.
And if we do, then we're going
to set a 1 in the continue bit
position.
And then we create
another chunk.
We'll replace the next
7 bits into the data
field of that chunk.
And then now we're actually done
encoding this integer value.
So we can place a 0
in the continue bit.
So that's how the
encoding works.
And decoding is just doing
this process backwards.
So you read chunks until
you find a chunk with a 0
continue bit.
And then you shift
all of the data values
left accordingly and
sum them together
to reconstruct the integer
value that you encoded.
One performance issue
that might occur here
is that when you're
decoding, you
have to check this continue
bit for every chunk
and decide what to do
based on that continue bit.
And this is actually
unpredictable branch.
So you can suffer from
branch mispredictions
from checking this continue bit.
So one way you can optimize
this is to get rid of these
continue bits.
And the idea here is
to first figure out
how many bytes
you need to encode
each integer in the sequence.
And then you group
together integers
that require the same
number of bytes to encode.
Use a run-length encoding idea
to encode all of these integers
together by using a header
byte, where in the header byte,
you use the lower 6 bits to
store the size of the group
and the highest 2 bits to
store the number of bytes each
of these integers
needs to decode.
And now all of the
integers in this group
will just be stored
after this header byte.
And we'd know exactly how many
bytes they need to decode.
So we don't need to store a
continue bit in these chunks.
This does slightly
increase the space usage.
But it makes decoding cheaper
because we no longer have
to suffer from
branch mispredictions
from checking this continue bit.
OK, so now we have to decode
these edge lists on the fly
as we're running our algorithm.
If we decoded everything
at the beginning,
we wouldn't actually
be saving any space.
We need to decode these
edges as we access them
in our algorithm.
Since we encoded
all of these edge
lists separately
for each vertex,
we can decode all
of them in parallel.
And each vertex just decodes
its edge list sequentially.
But what about
high-degree vertices?
If you have a
high-degree vertex,
you stop to decode its
edge list sequentially.
And if you're running
this in parallel,
this could lead
to load imbalance.
So one way to fix this is,
instead of just encoding
the whole thing sequentially,
you can chunk it up
into chunks of size T.
And then for each chunk,
you encode it like
you did before,
where you store the first value
relative to the source vertex
and then all of the other values
relative to the previous edge.
And now you can actually
decode the first value
here for each of these
chunks all in parallel
without having to wait for the
previous edge to be decoded.
And then this gives us
much more parallelism
because all of these chunks
can be decoded in parallel.
And we found that a value of
T-- where T is the chunk size--
between 100 and 10,000 works
pretty well in practice.
OK, so I'm not
going to have time
to go over the experiments.
But at a high level,
the experiments
show that compression
schemes do save space.
And serially, it's
only slightly slower
than the uncompressed version.
But surprisingly, when
you run it in parallel,
it actually becomes faster
than the uncompressed version.
And this is because these graph
algorithms are memory bound.
And we're using less memory.
You can alleviate this
memory subsystem bottleneck
and get better scalability.
And the decoding part of
these compressed algorithms
actually gets very
good parallel speedup
because they're just
doing local operations.
OK, so let me summarize now.
So we saw some properties
of real-world graphs.
We saw that they're quite
large, but they can still
fit on a multi-core server.
And they're relatively sparse.
They also have a power
law degree distribution.
Many graph algorithms are
irregular in that they involve
many random memory accesses.
So that becomes a bottleneck
of the performance
of these algorithms.
And you can improve performance
with algorithmic optimization,
such as using this
direction optimization
and also by creating
and exploiting
locality, for example, by using
this bit vector optimization.
And finally,
optimizations for graphs
might work well
for certain graphs,
but they might not work
well for other graphs.
For example, the direction
optimization idea
works well for power law
graphs but not for road graphs.
So when you're trying to
optimize your graph algorithm,
we should definitely test it
on different types of graphs
and see where it works well
and where it doesn't work.
So that's all I have.
If you have any
additional questions,
please feel free to
ask me after class.
And as a reminder, we have
a guest lecture on Thursday
by Professor Johnson of
the MIT Math Department.
And he'll be talking about
high-level languages,
so please be sure to attend.